is Eugene still going through his little
weeb phase yes he's pretty good at
saying stuff
yeah and he goes and then when he gets a
beer he goes be rudes
yeah everything Eugene Eugene is that
one person who went to Japan after
watching 200 anime yeah right like the
first two critical credit do yeah he's
he is trying yeah he's trying just you
don't have to say beer like beer or
death after you get us like yeah we know
we [__] got it for you yeah every
time there's an order come that comes
out remember like going to dinner with
them and every time an order would come
out you know we're after he's okay and
they'll bring out like karage and he was
like ah karage desk
and I was like
we're in a public setting here you just
said that is fried chicken that is meat
yes he's the type of guy who just like
sees what he sees in Genki and just like
immediately reflects the background like
this is
Eugene is a Vietnamese yeah so uh these
taxi drivers just weren't stopping for
me and I was like I better some [__]
white I'm like Eugene stand in front of
me Haley cause you're in Kyoto and I was
like yeah no they're probably just tired
of [__] [__] tourists yeah and I
was like from a distance Eugene they
might think you're Japanese hail them
sure enough hell one immediately got a
cabin that's all right let me take over
I was like I'm sick of this [__] the
Asian baby it works every time
she's just call it appears from boys
[__] this [__] but also that's kind of
hype
you know if I walk in they'll be like
what the [__] what is this white guy
doing wait when when we were in 20 yeah
do we do it and we make sometimes Joey
make we make Joey walking because Joey
you know out of all of us look at the
Motions
perfect Japanese yeah but there's also
the 0.5 seconds of panic from where the
moment they look at my face and they're
just like oh God yeah because you've got
a beard you know as soon as he as soon
as they started my mouth they're like oh
thank God but he looks more Japanese
than us so that's you know that helps
yeah with me for sure and it's not that
I won't get a seat it's that like I just
want to you know why would you stack the
cards you know what I mean yeah just
make it easier for me it's like why play
on hard difficult why plan legendary
difficulty when I can play on normal
videos you know it's just always that
panic when I walk into a bar and there's
like five seconds of panic on their face
and yeah to be like immediately have to
just talk more than I normally would
yeah yeah my first Japanese would be no
questions asked but immediately you stop
being like Oh young man thinking about
God yeah yeah yeah yeah I have to do
this thing now where like because
there's that point five seconds of panic
from seeing my face the moment
immediately just start talking yeah I
don't even give them a shadow of a Down
this is the Strat by the way if you do
if you are a foreign person uh you know
and you do know a little bit of Japanese
if you do actually want to get into some
bars where they might be a bit like no
you just have to immediately
yeah oh
yeah
I'll be like thanks god that's literally
is right
just the entire rugby team comes in
white people all right cool sit down
boys
I've noticed ever since like I've grown
like a little stubble I've I've I guess
I've like stopped being like mistaken
for Asian in Asian countries I don't
know what it is about the beard before
it was kind of like 50 50 you know I had
the tan skin but sometimes you know
maybe I'll be mistaken for a local like
even it's actually no especially in
[__] Thailand yeah like I remember I
remember this one time I was
um I was at a restaurant and you know
same same kind of Strat you go in you uh
kind of like have to like start speaking
Thai straight away and if you don't then
they're gonna think you're a foreigner
yeah so just just this day you know I
was uh
uh I went I went into this restaurant
with like a few friends uh just kind of
like forgot I was just like little space
cadet that day and uh person asked me uh
you know wait uh waitress asked me a
question uh just didn't hear it I was
like sorry and I I know you know out of
instinct and I was like immediately like
oh no sorry and then I started speaking
to life but just just that just that
millisecond of just just the sorry and
then she she immediately just flipped
into this guy's a tourist right and then
and so I um I start explaining to her
hey I want this I want that and she uh
in Thai by the way in like in local time
she she's just like uh my my no you need
to do this and I was just like and and I
was like I understand yeah this is what
I want again in Thai and she just she
would just refuse she she refused I get
that so often yeah man it's not even
funny like the mo like the you know I
understand like the initial reaction
they see my face they're like oh you're
not Japanese looking so I'll start
speaking in just the most broken English
possible yeah I'm gonna start explaining
[__] and then I respond back being like
[__] on this there yeah and then
they're like yes so anyway
[__] I just spoke Japanese I understand
[__] I'm one of you and I refuse to
leave this place until I'm treated
it is fun seeing the like relieved look
when you're like oh
yeah yeah yeah it's like nature is like
healing it's carrying all back oh my God
amazing
okay question uh Jerry because you've
been in the situation forever when you
see when you're like checking into a
hotel maybe you're out somewhere and you
see like somebody who's like English
speaking having like a lot of difficulty
uh with whatever they're doing do you
ever like help or you like
[Music]
it's uh it's probably 50 50. okay but
like sometimes like you know if I'm
saying like at a hotel right and the
person in front of me is like foreign
and then you know kind of struggling
then it's like well I want to get
checked in so I'll help him out they've
seen it was in front of you yeah but if
they're like another person yeah after
this I have to say it couldn't be me
I was just like I just came back to be
like let's see let's see how they
resolve this let's see how they pass
this test so it's a case-by-case I think
but like you know like there's every now
and then you know like I it could be
maybe be like you know Tokyo station or
something and I see like a family that's
like clearly struggling to get around
and then sometimes if I have time I'll
be like oh you're okay like let me help
you out stuff like that uh uh yeah but
it depends on my mood really like or if
I'm like I don't know if you're busy
like I get it you gotta go somewhere
yeah yeah exactly but sometimes I just
kind of sit back and be like I want to
see how they figure it out
I had a few interactions where I was
there's like one coffee shop and uh it
was a pretty big coffee shop actually it
was a pretty nice one um but they don't
they would call out your number
obviously in Japanese yeah yeah and uh
this person ordered after me and I I
figured that they were what the number
was because they were right after me and
uh yeah they they look like they're
having nightmare time ordering and then
I felt bad and then the number got
called and I went up to them and I was
like oh hey by the way that's your the
shows I'm pretty sure oh okay thanks but
then they they seemed really confused
that I came up to them and told them but
yeah they weren't going up and getting
their stuff and I was like oh okay
whatever yeah yeah there's other time um
I was checking in it was so bad uh I'll
check into the hotel and it was all
going well and the person next to me I
guess they started speaking in Japanese
to them uh you know and even though my
Japanese isn't like perfect I could like
hear that the way she was saying things
was like not great Japanese like it
didn't sound like natural I guess even
though like I'm not great anyway but
like the pronunciation I guess I don't
know me I'm the last person should be
judging
um she started speaking Japanese and she
started speaking Japanese and then she
just immediately was like oh [__] I
don't know what the [__] happening and
I it was kind of like I was like I was
like I don't want to help she's trying
so I was just checking in and it started
just getting more painful and more
pain-free right and I was like do you
need do you need help she's like no I'm
okay I'm like okay thank God I was like
it only took me like 30 minutes to check
in I think this should have taken
forever